let's just totally jump onto a different
subject i want to talk about what's
going on with uh sussman the clinton
campaign and all that stuff
so we have this story from cnn and it's
from may 17th just something to kick
things off prosecutors say clinton
campaign lawyer tried to manipulate the
fbi with trump russia tip at first
durham uh as first durham trial opens so
we've heard a lot about this the the
trial of uh um
from you know of sussman michael sussman
do you want to break down what this is
all about what's the elevator pitch on
this story for people who aren't
familiar with what's going on all right
let me give you the triangle and and the
quick and dirty is it's all up for free
at durhamwatch.com on fight with cash
you could literally get everything i'm
about to tell you all the documents so
you can read them yourselves all the
transcripts all the judicial pleadings
and everything over at durhamwatch.com
but here's the triangle okay right
democratic party under hillary clinton
is running for president and they're
like okay we are going to do a couple of
things we are going to run two lines of
effort to take out then candidate trump
we are going to use the fbi to do it
we're going to use the media to do it
and then the hillary clinton is going to
be the third piece of that triangle
their campaign so the steele dossier
we've talked about that in the show
before the hired help from overseas to
filtering unverified information to the
fbi the fbi knowingly lying to a federal
court to surveil donald trump and of
course the hillary clinton campaign
funded that entire thing we know that we
proved that in the russia gate
investigation john durham's next
indictment after this one is the
denchenko case he's trying in the fall
is the christopher steele source the
takedown of that line of effort one line
of effort two was the hillary clinton
campaign on a parallel track
running let's just call it the alphabet
server deal right because it's just
easier to quantify as that that's what
sussman's on trial for
michael sussman was one of the head
lawyers for the hillary clinton campaign
at this law firm perkins coie right
hillary clinton campaign paid them 50 to
100 million dollars for services
they took that money and doled it out to
people like fusion gps christopher
steele and the alpha bank server this
parallel track what are they doing on
this
they said okay the steele.ca route isn't
enough we need a backup so they went out
and hired this tech guy
rodney jaffe okay
and basically said we need you to go
find a connection between trump and
russia and here's where we want you to
do get technical get us computer details
that show trump tower is connected to
russia through this bank right so so
they're they're fabricating a narrative
literally and and what's come out in
this trial is is is exactly that
the f the information was taken the fbi
and the fbi said the next day they knew
it was false that's what the agent
testified to during this case and so
russia gate should have stopped
immediately well russia should have
stopped and and but it didn't because
you had a couple of corrupt fbi cops
comey mccabe strzok this hyde guy who
were running the whole thing but not
only were they running it internally
they were running it with the media what
came out in this trial is all these guys
at michael sussman fusion gps hillary
clinton they were all meeting with the
media they were sending christopher
steele to meet with the media they were
sending rodney jaffe to meet with the
media why circular reporting the fbi is
like oh look look what cnn's publishing
must be true we have a source that says
that here's the kicker the whole thing
both christopher steele and rodney jaffe
fbi sources the entire time
and they both got fired why
for leaking to the media but here's what
the fbi did they kept taking their intel
to prosecute their case against donald
trump once he became president so
it is a it is the biggest criminal
enterprise in u.s history from my
perspective as a former federal
prosecutor i'm probably biased because
the russia gate
you know living through that um you know
running that investigation but
it's a story that needs to be told and i
i think the only way going to sort of
the accountability portion because
you can run constitutional oversight in
congress and we got 17 people fired
including comey and that okay that's a
start what john durham has done is
basically mobilized this thing and said
okay i'm going to take some people out
with indictments so so the russia
collusion narrative is false 100
we we learned that with the end of the
mueller probe right away that it was a
lot of nonsense he said it too yeah but
you uh i think you along with devin
nunes
you know you you had a report basically
a year before the end of the molar probe
i think it was so we've consistently
learned that something was just which is
not true in all of this but now we
actually have in the investigation that
from the get-go fbi knew it was not true
so a lot of this information
did hillary clinton
directly know what they were doing in
terms of fabricating the narrative and
here's the kicker uh you know just real
quick yes she did or she did she did but
the kicker is
we knew it we were able to prove it with
classified information documents that
were coming in slowly but we couldn't
tell the world what happens now hillary
clinton's campaign manager from 2016
robbie mook testifies for the defense
in the sussman prosecution and literally
testifies under oath and says oh yeah
hillary clinton not only knew about it
acceded to it and directed us to go and
leak this bogus intel
to the media wow that's that's the most
damning statement to come out of this
trial watergate on steroids huh yeah man
and it's in it i think the trial wraps
up tomorrow and um you know look the
best if people want to understand
russiagate you need to do two things go
read the nunes memo which which we wrote
four pages it'll take you 12 minutes
take 90 minutes of your life and go
watch the plot against the president is
there
is there some kind of like um
what's how do i describe this
is is there is there for is there some
reason why the people who believed this
are the same people who believe jesse
smilet
yeah look the one unifying factor on all
of this the one the one thing that threw
the fbi's top level off and became total
partisan hacks was their unified hatred
for donald trump that's what it was it's
it is corrupted our law enforcement
industry from just the top level the the
main guys they're great but here's the
here's the thing the cast of characters
that read the hillary clinton email
investigation the server thing
same fbi agents involved in this case
and the steele dossier trump derangement
syndrome why did they dislike him so
much
that i don't know i mean i honestly i
can't answer that question i have no
idea but it's never been an issue i
served in democratic justice departments
republican justice you just did the
mission you're just like this is a job
this is easy this is a fun part go put
bad guys away they were just like
nope king comey was in there hillary
clinton hillary clinton clinton and the
media and they were basically
like we are going to take out trump and
then once he won they were like okay
we screwed that up but we're still going
to take them out and they continue to
bogus do you have any idea how much
taxpayer money it costs to run these
investigations
you have any idea it's it's it's
hundreds of millions of dollars to do
this kind of surveillance work on a
target it's insane and it was all it was
all bogus now how much of this is normal
politics do they do this all the time no
no
i mean this is that fisa court the
special court whatever you want to call
i used to do it to manhunt terrorist
that's what it's for you know to protect
the nation it's not for a political
campaign to come in and say
we're going to create a national
security issue and oh by the way the
target's my political so so why isn't
hillary clinton in jail
ma'am so look proving that is going to
be very hard that she
broke a federal law now what you can do
and what john durham's doing i think is
building a conspiracy case behind these
indictments because he said in federal
court in writing on his pleadings he
said judge there's a joint venture
conspiracy it's a legal term what does
that mean he's like judge he said that
to the judge oh yeah
it's on durhamwatch.com go get the
pleading wow it's his under oath
statement basically that's what a
pleading is to a federal judge and he's
saying not only is rodney jaffe the tech
giant the tech guy a target of my
investigation but i am looking at
multiple people in the media i'm in i'm
interrogating fbi agents who worked on
this case and also people on the hillary
clinton campaign he can't name those
people but he can give him my title and
he's telling the world i'm conducting a
criminal conspiracy investigation
because this didn't happen with one or
two people so two-part question for you
so
what needs to happen in your opinion to
restore faith in these institutions and
then what happens to the country if that
faith in these institutions isn't
restored what happens is what you see a
continuation of what's going on right
now and it doesn't just trickle into
just the political sphere it trickles
into everything when you're talking
about is the fbi doing the work across
the country to reduce crime
whatever type of murder guns
narco trafficking human trafficking
everybody loses faith in their ability
just to do those few things and then
we're just completely screwed
but
i don't the fix is the man the manpower
right the whoever runs these agencies
you have to go find that guy and chris
ray is definitely not that guy the guy
who's running it now he's almost as bad
as comey because he's allowed this
entire thing to go on for four or five
years now and unless you get rid of
these guys but the political leadership
doesn't want to and this is this is the
problem i have with my doj my former
place of work they always champion
themselves as being like we're
apolitical we are historically apart we
don't take our orders from the president
well you actually do
and you allowed a presidential political
candidate to give you your orders and to
pay you and to pay for corruption to
take over the top level of the fbi and
you need accountability you need some of
those people to be convicted in federal
court that's a piece of it then you need
to put the right people in place
i'm kind of disillusioned to be honest i
know you know when when when the email
thing was going on i love how to you
know most democrats it's a joke
you know they have a meme where they
amongst themselves will say like but her
emails whenever something crazy happens
put her emails and i'm like
dude yeah like
someone working in public office
destroyed public records
that's crazy they don't care i know it
like dude if my attitude is i was always
a trumps not that bad kind of guy like i
didn't vote for him the first time what
from the second second time because i
just joe biden was just so awful and i
liked i liked the second term agenda but
i was always like very early on when
trump was running and everyone's
screaming about screaming about him i
was always uh yeah but trump's not that
bad i mean like this is crazy he's
there's worse than hitler what are you
talking about calm down dude well i
think the part of the problem people
have is the double standard
um i read a story about a
naval officer he was on a submarine
and took a photo of
where he worked his sub in a hallway
nothing classified just to show his kid
and it got out that he had taken this
photo
and because it's it's all classified
they uh indicted him he was prosecuted i
think he did a little bit of jail time
for one single photo that wasn't
exposing anything sensitive at all
meanwhile you have hillary clinton who
had a private server with god knows how
many emails what 30 000 emails on it and
and not only was
all of this classified information and
information that was born classified
on this server but this server was
exposed to other nations and was and we
had vulnerabilities to where she had
vulnerabilities to where all all of this
documentation was available to to china
to russia to people who could weaponize
that information against the united
states so when people look at those two
circumstances you got a guy who just
wanted to show a picture to his kid well
jail time and then this offense and
absolutely nothing is going to happen to
this person it just it it it's
it
i could see how the country would be
disillusioned and thinking that we're
basically a banana republic where if
you're a certain part of the political
class if you come from a certain
pedigree then you're above the law and
the rest of us just have to to deal with
was it wasn't there some guy who went on
reddit and he was like i need to figure
out how to delete emails from a vip do
you know about this story for hillary
clinton yeah oh yeah there was like
smack literally smashing of servers
there's people like googling how to
delete stuff there was a guy
using hammers on phones but there was
one story i don't i don't know uh if
it's verified or whatever but someone
apparently this is the story okay so
somebody went on reddit and said i need
to find a way to remove someone from a
bunch of emails they're very vip and
then once the like so it was like it was
an old post someone found it and they
were like yo i think this is the guy who
works for hillary who is posting this so
i it's an old story i don't know the
full details on but there was tons of
stuff like that at the very least the
smashing cell phones of the hammer
but yeah it doesn't do anything it's
stupid but it's funny yeah
when i saw hillary's um
emails released to the public through uh
wikileaks and i read about um sydney
blumenthal talking to her like so many
emails between her and sidney blumenthal
and his company osprey global solutions
they're like hillary you know when we
get into libya we're gonna set up osprey
to run guns basically for this new
puppet uh government that you're gonna
set up so she's like all right sid and
she sends it over to her whoever her
manager or assistant or whatever to read
these like so she's basically took us to
war to set her buddy up with an arms
deal i mean it's com and but so i read
that i was like well logic dictates i
will not vote for that i don't i no
longer support that maybe it's always
been that corrupt but i mean
there's some sunshine let's let's let's
throw some shade at the media real quick
one of my favorite moments
was when i think it was in the 2016
debates trump says hillary clinton at
acid washed her server
and nbc news issued a fact check
saying false hillary clinton did not put
a corrosive chemical on her computer and
it was like what what that's not that's
not what trump was saying that's got to
be the onion what who did that yeah yeah
nbc news yeah i think it might have been
abc let me let me but just that's just a
piece of it that's that that's part of
the problem you're saying how do you fix
it i forgot to address it you how i
don't know if you can i don't know
what's easier to fix i think personally
i could go in and fix the fbi in five
months i don't know how you fix the
media you guys are the experts there
like how do you get the ability for five
years half the world and half of america
thinks russia gate and donald trump
actually colluded with russia they are
now finally starting to pull back those
stories because of these prosecutions
but how do you stop them from they they
knew the facts back then they just
didn't want to report it here check this
out can we pull this up can we get it it
says the claim trump says clinton acid
washed her email servers the truth
clinton's team used an app called
bleachbit she did not use a corrosive
chemical no no
nbc news fact check
welcome to the modern media my friends
amazing and that's the problem and how
do you fix that i don't know the answer
to that i don't know how you fix the
media i think that's a harder fix than
the government thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there